Speaker 1: Now, I want to talk about kind
of the sideshow there. There's always with
every real story and the situation in Del Rio,
Texas, with the Haitian migrants is a very real
story. Joe Biden is not putting forth a sort of
coherent package of what it is that should happen
and that needs to be done. But. There's always
a sideshow and the sideshow here is Fox News
reporter Peter Doocy with a bizarre gotcha attempt
with Jen Psaki, the White House press secretary
yesterday focusing on has Joe Biden been to
the border in his life? That's the question.
This is just so pathetic. And the problem with
this is that it generates the idea that these are
sort of like valid questions and the right way to
hold the administration accountable. This is just
gutter trash. OK, let's take a look at the video.
Speaker 2: Has President Biden ever been
to the southern border
Speaker 3: in his life?
Yes. I will have to get a look
back in my history books and
check the times he's been to the southern one.
Speaker 2: I've been looking all morning and
we cannot find any record of him visiting the
border as president, vice president, senator,
or even as a concerned citizen. Why would that be?
Speaker 3: I can check and see when the last time
or when he may have been. But tell
me more about why you're asking,
Speaker 2: because this is a president who makes
a point when there are disasters in this country
like a wildfire or a hurricane to go and see for
himself firsthand what the needs are of the local
community so that he can have an informed covid to
make policy. Why does he do that? Why does he go
down to Del Rio, Texas, and see what's going on?
Speaker 3: Well, first of all, Peter, I think the
situation at the border is the result of a broken
system. And the president certainly relies on
his experience. So whether it was the work he
did to address root causes as vice president,
his efforts when he was in the Senate
to support comprehensive immigration
reform are steps that at a time or being done and
work toward in a bipartisan way, something that
certainly we think should be the case today.
Speaker 1: So, you know, the answer from Jen
Psaki is, OK, but there are real questions
here. As we discussed in the last segment,
you're opposed to the treatment of the migrants,
but at the same time, you're not really improving
the sanitation and food situation. But at the
same time, these are, at least for now, people
who are here illegally. But at the same time,
even though you want to be more humane, you're,
you know, expelling people without any real
analysis of the situation. And it's not really
clear what solution you're proposing. And Biden's
approval is declining. There's a real situation
here that could develop into a very significant
drag for Joe Biden. But whether Biden has been
to the border is really completely irrelevant.
And it also bears mentioning, I guess, that even
just going to a location when you're a president
doesn't necessarily really do much. I mean,
remember when after the hurricanes in I think it
was I think it was 2017 when Donald Trump went to
Puerto Rico. Oh, wow. He went, wow, that's great.
He shot rolls of paper towels like basketballs
and appeared completely insensitive and arguably
made things worse by just bringing his whole
entourage and and and team. And, you know, the
entire apparatus that travels with the president
to a place that was trying to recover still didn't
have power back on in many places, et cetera. So
merely going is no big victory. And unfortunately,
this counts as like valid journalism among many
on the right. This they see Peter Doocy ask
his questions with his, you know, upspeak
and bizarre delivery. And they say, wow, he really
exposed this administration. No, he really didn't.
And particularly in this situation, this is not a
natural, you know, a natural disaster where you go
and tour damage and and console victims. This is
a this is an immigration situation with complex
legal circumstances. What would even be
the point of Joe Biden going down there,
like aside from whether in general a president
needs to go somewhere in order to properly deal
with the situation? In this particular case,
it seems Joe Biden going down there would it
would at minimum add nothing and at worst possibly
even make the situation more complicated. So
it's another failed gotcha. But sadly, in
this country, given the lack of, you know,
sort of awareness that so many people have about
what are the important political questions and
how do we figure out problems in in society
and in government, this is this is considered
really powerful journalism. And that's
probably why Fox News keeps Peter
Doocy in the White House press briefing
room. What do you think needs to happen
on the border with this particular situation? Find
me on Twitter at David Pakman and let me know.